لا هو بالاخر كما ذكرت انه
المرور بهذه التجارب ومش ناقصها بالنسبه
لحياه الشخص بالعكس يضيف هي بحث عن شيء
يعني
انه من يبلغ العشرين وما يكون عنده تجربه
باليسار يكون بالعقل واللي بصير عمره 35
وبيبقى داخل هذه المنظومه بيكون بصير ايضا
بالعقل
يعني هون بدنا نقول انه اذا بدك
كونك لبناني كان بمعنى ما امتياز
كان امتياز لانه بتعيش ببلد كان يسمح لك
جرب صحيح تطلع من التجربه متعلم شغله او
شغلتين
للاسف الشديد بمجتمعات اخرى حكموها العسكر
والامن مكه مرتاح لالك تعمل هيك يعني
اذا تعلمت من التجربه
فيستحسن تنسى علمك تنسى ما تعلمته او تطلع
من البلد لحتى تقول هالشي تقول شو تعلمت
منها التجربه بس اذا بدك تعبر عن اللي
تعلمته انت بالبلد فالعرض سلامتك
فهل معمل واحد كمان بحس بدين
لبنان التقليدي عليه لبنان القديم
على كل نواقص وقصور وما اخذ المحقق يعني
بحس بدين هذا اللبنان على تشكل اي وعي
لابناء جيلي انا صحيح
[موسيقى]